question I have for you because I'm
gonna make it quick the organization
that told you about that I was starting
to spotlight to help other creatives in
my college get their projects up we
already started it right now we have 23
people that are in there we don't
haven't even started school yet so I
have 23 people in there that's
interested in coming in my question to
you is what is one of the first things
that you would do with all of those
people to help them figure out what
their why is and just help them get
their own projects off the ground this
foundation for me always starts with
core values that start with your one
word whether you want to use the one
word exercise or something else I think
understanding your most important core
value I think really really really helps
it's just gives you your compass then I
would look at purpose coming from your
pain so what did they struggle with who
would do what I want to help now like I
think that's at the core of their why a
lot of people run a to run away and
forget the pain that they went through
but it's actually the greatest gift that
you have instead of running instead of
running away from instead of hiding from
it embrace and insulate this is a
struggle that I went through and now I
want to help other people who are going
through that either you have come
through it and you have answer this to
share or you're still going through it
and your journey is the value that
you're giving to people I think that's
the foundation and then then it's to the
creative talent to your what you're good
at
now how do we express it right so like
if somebody's a youtuber somebody's a
visual artist or somebody is a musician
or like there's lots of ways to then
articulate through your creativity the
message that you have but it starts with
your core value then it goes to your
your mission the pain that you're trying
to solve and then to the artistic
expression what is their main objective
is just to make money or make profit you
know just finding a way to build the
business to make money as quickly as
possible
no can does that interfere with their
why or
that like you know help it more because
I see people say don't focus on that it
doesn't interfere with their why they
just don't have a wine okay and if you
don't have a wine in entrepreneurship
you're done
money is a funny thing money money is
just an exchange of value and money is
super important for anybody who says
money is unimportant you know they
haven't had success in in any kind of
business endeavor but it's just not it's
just that number one money's not number
one there's something above money that's
the why that's the passion like your has
to be some if your image just for the
money you will quit you wait you'll give
up it's just it's too hard it's too
difficult you might be able to make some
quick short-term arbitrage right like
you might be able to take advantage of
an opportunity that comes to you but
you're not gonna you're not gonna win
big in your industry if you don't
absolutely love it in the beginning of
anything you could win just by showing
up just by being there but if you want
to win long-term you have to actually be
good and to get good you have to have
the passion for it I think people who
say that their images to the moment
they're just confused they just don't
have a strong Y yet they don't know what
it is and if I knew I don't I don't
bring those people into my incubator or
into your program unless you help them
figure out what their strong lying is
because they're not gonna win they're
not gonna win long-term I see how is
your responsibility to help help them
see the light like to help them find the
purpose you know if you have the ability
then you have the responsibility if you
can then you must and if you've got
these you know 23 kids and in half of
them are in it just for the money you
you have to switch their mindset for
them because that was economic yes sir
and either like freshmen they're just
coming into the college so that's even
better
that's even better that's why I love you
just to tell you one last thing before I
let you go because I don't want to take
up too much of your time I know this
twelve-year-old girl and this inspired
me yesterday co-worker of mine his
sister built a bakery business where
she's selling baked goods like chocolate
covered
strawberries cupcakes things like that
to individuals and this girl she and not
profit while she is doing great profit
wise but still at the same thing she got
a hustle and debt that in his self
because I was like when I was twelve I
was worried about teen titans and all
these little cartoons and stuff and just
to see a twelve-year-old girl doing that
that's incredible to me that's reason
why I told her I'm buying 50 of whatever
you got I might not personally eat it I
might give it away and stuff like that
during events but I'm buying 50 or
whatever you got just to support that
because that was incredible so two
things come to mind
the first is your story is important
mm-hmm right like just what you said
like I will buy 50 of whatever you're
selling even if I won't ever use it or
eat it just because I want to support
you speaks volumes that's accessible to
anybody that's not because this girl is
so insanely special like she is but
she's just as special as everybody
watching that's the goal that I have for
every entrepreneur like I want people
buying your stuff because they love your
story they love your message they love
what you stand for and they'll fight to
spend money even if they'll never use
the thing that you're selling because
your mission and your story is so good
everybody watching could get that for
themselves too if you share your story
if you show your heart the better you
are at explaining your story your
mission your why making it important
then the more people will rally to
support you one other thing and this one
is for you what you ended that last
question which was I don't want to take
up too much of your time
mm-hmm I want you to switch it switch
the mindset to a place of gratitude I
want you to say I'm I'm super grateful
for the time you're spending with me as
opposed to that you are taking up
somebody else's time you can show
gratitude without putting yourself down
okay right like the tinging up means
you're not worth working on yeah right
so don't say I'm taking up your time
don't apologize don't say sorry for
taking so long with the question or
right if I didn't want to talk to you I
wouldn't talk to you everybody want to
answer another question I'd say thank
you for joining man and go on
the next thing right so but it's fine
because it's all from love like what
you're trying to do is say I'm really
grateful for the time that you're
spending with me to help me with my
questions so express that as opposed to
putting yourself down to push somebody
else top right you're not taking up my
time but if you were taking up my time
you wouldn't be here
I like talking to you this is great
thank you don't put yourself down to
build somebody else though when you're
trying to show gratitude of course thank
you and I appreciate the time that you
have given me there we go if you want to
know what myself and other successful
entrepreneurs think about how to build
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every morning
for the next 250 for mornings I will
send you a video that is 30 seconds to 5
minutes long absolutely for free that as
you watch them it'll help you build
unstoppable confidence check out the
link in the description below surround
yourself with greatness
realizing that any big endeavor is the
collection of a lot of small steps if
you're doing work that you love you're
more likely to follow through raise your
standard Apple epic or its core value is
that passion not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your acceptance of
me if you want to learn more on how to
find your why I highly recommend
checking out the video right next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there anybody watching this you may not
even know it you all have a why
everybody has a wife